the sound of salvation in the skies over
northwest spain
right now every drop of water matters
from these hilltops it is clear the
situation below is dire
on the ground things are much worse
tabara is on fire
[Applause]
panic residents look for any help they
can find
as the flames near
with these wildfires comes chaos
desperation
the animals she says are still inside
the shed
trying to save their homes their
livestock their livelihoods every second
counts
the town of tabara is a key strategic
location the command and control center
based here is coordinating air and
ground operations throughout the castile
leon province
precious little rest for teams working
around the clock to keep pace with
wildfires in real time
this is my
25 year has it ever been this bad
no of course absolutely you know
the climate change is
very present and the situation is
related with the dry
with the drought
these fires have a pulse the most danger
firefighters say is the late afternoon
the hottest part of the day when the sun
is highest and the winds are strongest
this fire is happening all across this
part of spain but these flames represent
a kind of change in the profile of these
wildfires the fires are moving from the
hill country
down they've burned up all the fuel they
could find in the hills and now they're
looking for more fuel moving downwards
towards more populated areas
as they put out one fire more come alive
climate change experts say has altered
the behavior of wildfires they now burn
faster hotter and longer
people living here say everything
catches fire
and you cannot trust the ground
zane basravi al jazeera